they were ominous words from the russian
president any nation is able to
distinguish true patriots from scum and
traitors i am convinced a necessary
purge of society will only strengthen
our country this is very scary language
he says you know russia has to cleanse
itself you see so many echoes of
the soviet union now and what what he's
doing words of fear and intimidation
evoking some of the darkest chapters of
modern history as vladimir putin
intensifies information's oppression at
home and aggression abroad
leaving his western rivals to grapple
with what could be next yesterday
president biden said that in his opinion
war crimes have been committed in
ukraine
personally i agree there remains
concerns that russia may further
escalate its brutal assault by using
chemical weapons in ukraine so nato
members are continuing to hold the line
they will deliver weapons and
humanitarian support but their fighters
will stay on the sidelines nato has a
responsibility to prevent this conflict
from escalating further there's no such
thing as a no-fly zone light
a no-fly zone means that you're in in a
conflict with russia there's also the
question of china on friday joe biden
will speak with xi jinping a collision
of two superpowers and strategic world
views this call also comes that we have
made clear our deep concerns about
china's alignment with russia and the
potential implications and consequences
of that if china chooses to support
russia the u.s warns swift economic
sanctions will follow but the country
could also choose to become a peacemaker
using its economic leverage and xi
jinping's long-time relationship with
the russian president to bring about a
ceasefire heather eric's west global
news washington